bonjour José Cachin je suis maire
adjoint délégué à la culture et à
l'événementiel à montinil Bretonneux si
je suis devant vous c'est simplement
pour vous donner trois bonnes raisons
d'aller assister à un spectacle qui
s'intitule à fleur
[Musique]
d'ignon la première raison c'est que
cette pièce de théâtre rend hommage aux
comédie sociale de Charlie Chaplin et de
Buster Kiton la deuxième raison c'est
que c'est un univers de magie et de
tendresse et ça on en a bien besoin de
nos jours et la troisième raison c'est
que c'est une plongée l'espace d'une
soirée dans les années 30 avec un
univers absolument poétique et comme le
disait très bien comme le dit très bien
Jean-Pierre Siméon qui est poète lui
aussi c'est certainement la poésie qui
sauvera le monde alors autorisons nous
l'espace d'une soirée à y croire alors
si vous êtes convaincu par ces trois
arguments moi je vous invite fortement à
venir assister à à fleur d'oignon cette
magnifique pièce de théâtre qui se
déroulera le mardi 28 novembre à 20h30 à
la salle
jacbrelle